alors plus des paillettes la première
plume et bien si fabienne qui est globe
trotteuse et qui est allé se balader ou
pas figurez vous que j'ai une drôle
d'histoire à vous raconter je n'avais
rien à faire samedi soir je me suis dit
quoi faire à paris je me suis promené
j'ai mis mes baskets j'ai branché mais
l'antenne c'est fait pour ça quand on
développe trotter et là je suis tombée
sur un gros poisson et ce poisson fêter
quoi alors personnes auraient pauvres
c'était un navire un navire mais pas
n'importe quel navire un navire qui
glisse qui chante et qui danse en fait
c'était le batofar et c'est là que je
suis allé c'est un nouveau lieu de
programmation en ce moment à paris il ya
pas mal de choses qui s'y passe j'ai
tendu l'oreille alors gip entendu le
chant des sirènes
mais le son des dj et le chant
d'artistes exceptionnels
voilà on va voir on va voir tout de
suite
nom de scène batofar nationalité
irlandaise date de naissance 1957
signe particulier 45 mètres de long pour
520 tonnes et des tonnes et des tonnes
et des tonnes d'histoires
vous avez le pied marin alors suivez le
guide boris l'un des capitaines de
l'équipage bonjour vous dévoile un
nouveau piratage on va voir comment ça
se passe par là bas je vais moi alors là
on arrive vraiment sur le sur le rebord
la coursive c'est directement par là et
là nous arrivons sur le pont arrière dit
la poupe au pied du phare là haut c'est
là où on vient voir aussi des coups en
extérieur quand il fait beau uniquement
quand il pleut on arrête ça c'est
monsieur le dj de ce soir qui va faire
avant après les pas pendant le batofar
c'est ça aussi c'est les piratages c'est
d'arriver à prendre le lieu qui n'a rien
à voir normalement avec les spectacles
en l'occurrence le bateau fabre et
d'exploiter un maximum de tout cet
espace qui sont là dans cette grande
carcasse métallique
[Musique]
il
pour toi sur le batofar cette fois là
pour nous c'est la première fois qu'on y
allait y passer un moment de
deux des fortunes au bord de l'eau c'est
avant la rentrée c'est agréable de
passer le temps ici prendre l'air avec
les corons verts
oui d'après vous avez commandé 100 dans
le concert au bois ou bien on est là
pour ça là c'est l'entrée principale
c'est là où tout le monde rentre le
début mais ça va tu toi et on passe à
tabac ça c'est que la monnaie
le but du jeu sur le bateau phare c'est
ça aussi c'est d'arriver à découvrir de
voir des choses qui justement sont
pleine évolution en plein métissage
maintenant tout le monde écoute de tout
dans le cas des musiques électroniques
c'est quelque chose qui commence à
rentrer dans les moeurs et qui commence
à mettre tous les musiciens en contact
les uns des autres avec des influences
diverses etc ça c'est qu'on arrive
vraiment à des hybrides particulier
maintenant
[Musique]
au niveau de l'équipage ya plein de chef
il ya plein de capitaine quand même moi
je suis capitaine de la programmation
musicale mais aussi le capital des
institutionnels le capitaine artistique
il ya le capitaine du son il ya le
capital de la régie générale enfin bon
c'est toute une équipe autour de plein
de choses différentes
[Musique]
le batofar qui se déplacent c'est un
gros gros soucis en fait parce qu'il n'y
a pas de moteur du tout là c'est
vraiment le bâton le poser il fait farhi
tourne sur lui-même
c'est aussi surtout pour ça qu'on invite
toutes les villes européennes à venir
faire la fête à bord et se présenter ça
a commencé par berlin c'était
l'ouverture par barcelone à petit côté
latin et là on va bientôt embarquer par
budapest fin du mois de septembre
commencent à débarquer sa lettre le
plasticien qui va arriver commencé à
s'occuper du bateau lui mettre du bois
le travail et enfin bon et le festival
lui en novembre
peut-être qu'on nous vend pour le
festival de budapest
on va remonter le ballon on va partir
par là je pense plutôt au revoir
[Musique]